a placebo is a treatment with zero
therapeutic value but magical healing
power common placebos include sugar
pills inert sailin injections other
procedures and surgeries that are
completely fake placebos are especially
effective to treat pain chronic stress
related diseases like insomnia and forms
of depression what most don't realize is
that while placebos are fake the placebo
effect does it's magic even if you get
real treatments from a normal doctor
placebos tend to follow one simple rule
the more ritualized and extreme the fake
treatment the more effective their
effect in short sugar pills work well
sham surgery works wonders since
standard doctor appointments are often
highly ritualized the placebo effect is
part of the cure we think we receive to
understand this better let's look at mr.
and mrs. Martin who both suffer chronic
back pain mr. Martin feels the pain
first and he decides to go see a doctor
who diagnoses osteoporosis and treats
him with physiotherapy after a few days
of treatment mr. Martin feels better he
starts to track the progress of his pain
he soon learns that he always goes to
the doctor on the days when the pain is
the worst and always feels better soon
after he becomes a big advocate for
physiotherapy and recommends it to his
wife and she joins him but do we really
know that the therapy works despite
months of therapy things get worse for
both mr. and mrs. Martin together they
go to the hospital where mr. Martin's
doctor prescribes painkillers mrs.
Martin decides to get a second opinion
her new doctor has recently learned that
for some chronic pain placebos work
equally well instead of giving mrs.
Martin painkillers
the doctor prescribes simple sugar pills
though he tells mrs. Martin that they
are paying
the next day they both feel much better
mr. Martin notices that he has no
problem sawing wood and mrs. Martin can
easily put on her shoes she can confirm
that the painkillers work but do they
really unfortunately it doesn't take
long before the pain comes back and they
return to the hospital
mr. Martin is now treated with
vertebroplasty a popular treatment
offered to people who suffer from back
pain due to osteoporosis to administer
it the doctors inject cement directly
into his vertebrae the bones that form
the spinal column mrs. Martin's doctor
simply has her smell a container full of
cement and then administers a saline
injection which does nothing
her doctor learned about this placebo
from research published in the u.s.
National Library of Medicine it showed
that a large randomized controlled trial
found no benefit of vertebroplasty over
a sham procedure right after the surgery
the Martin's meet in the lobby and share
their experience of the process both
feel great mrs. Martin invites her
husband for ice cream as her treatment
was so much cheaper so what's happening
here there are a couple of theories that
try to explain the placebo effect first
there is regression to the mean mr.
Martin like most of us thinks about
treatment when his symptoms are
particularly bad he goes to see a doctor
and soon after feels better if we look
at the natural course of many illnesses
we understand that pain over time comes
and goes in swings and usually regresses
to the mean we don't know if the doctor
or placebo had anything to do with the
improvement
then there is classical conditioning
most treatments including vertebroplasty
are delivered in a context of rituals
that include social signals physical
cues and verbal suggestions mr. Martin's
brain interprets such cues and elicits
expectations memories and emotions it
releases endorphins and other chemicals
that make him feel good and lower his
perception of pain so it becomes a
self-fulfilling prophecy with a belief
that he feels better leads him to feel
better and there is confirmation bias as
soon as mrs. Martin takes the sugar pill
she thinks she will feel better then she
focuses only on the things that confirm
that she is better she doesn't realize
that she still has trouble doing many
other things while all three ideas
probably work together there is another
theory so-called mirror neurons might
also play a role a new and growing body
of evidence points at brain cells the
mirror behavior the cells fire when one
acts and when one observes the same
action performed by another as mrs.
Martin talks to the doctor parts of the
doctors brain will mirror parts of her
brain and part of her brain will mirror
his as a result the structure of her
brain changes and she feels less pain
the neurophysiologist giacomo rizzolatti
who discovered mirror neurons suggests
that this process bypasses consciousness
and provides a direct mapping of sensory
information onto motor structures
placebo a Latin word that means I will
please have been used for thousands of
years placebo effects have been
discussed for centuries an influential
study from 1955 by Henry Kay Beecher
Harvard titled the powerful placebo
established the idea that the effect is
clinically important today the placebo
effect is well recognized and
scientifically so significant that any
new pain medication that seeks Food and
Drug Administration approval in the
United States needs to show that it
works better than a placebo treatment in
so-called randomized controlled trials
the gold standard of medical research
one group of patients is given the new
medication one a control group receives
a placebo
neither the doctors who hand out the
medication nor the patients know who
gets what once the trial is over results
are compared if the new medication works
significantly better than a placebo it's
allowed to be sold the trial is
surprisingly difficult from 10 new drugs
entering the test one gets approval if a
placebo study proves that an existing
standard medical procedure is
ineffective like in the case of
vertebroplasty competent doctors stop
prescribing it and we can speak of
medical reversal to find out if an
existing treatment works or if it's
healing power is just the result of the
placebo effect we can administer
treatment without the knowledge of the
patients in one such experiment it was
shown that if a painkiller is
administered by a hidden robot pump
patients demanded twice the dose
compared to when the drug is injected by
a nurse this would suggest that if a
patient is completely unaware that
treatment is being given the treatment
is just half as effective the placebo
effect counts for the other half
honest placebo studies go even further
because deception is ethically
questionable researchers have now
started to do clinical trials in which
people are told that all they get is a
sugar pill with placebo printed all over
the packaging and even then the placebo
effect does it's magic and helps you
feel better
one experiment at the Harvard Medical
School show that people suffering from
irritable bowel syndrome who were taking
the honest placebo doubled their rate of
improvement compared to the control
group what do you think how can we make
sure that the medicine we are
prescribing is not only effective thanks
to the placebo effect wilmore placebo
research reveal that many standard
medical treatments offered in some of
the best hospitals around the world are
shams and how can we research the power
of placebos ourselves at home without
putting anyone in danger
[Music]
if you like this video and the way we
explain the subject subscribe to our
channel we try to explain complex
subjects and simple language and
cartoons to support students all around
the world in their learning if you want
to support us you can go to WWE and calm
sprouts and donate just $1 from many
fans makes a big difference
you